why why would you not want to push the
benchmark of pawn yeah
i know i i like it low quality so i
don't feel like
yeah we know we know no no what do you
mean don't feel the shame do you feel
shame by watching something that's high
quality when it's porn yeah when it's
too well produced i'm like [ __ ] what
like i can see everything yeah man i
i just when that dude shoved his hand in
there i was like
what what led me to be ignore what you
are watching but we're just like
if you imagine like quality of
production on like the shows that you
recommended yeah
on the hentai that you recommend would
you not want to see no i don't want that
why why
i don't want that to be a different i
like i i don't want my anime and porn
look exactly the same i want a clear
difference in quality
always why same reason why like you know
when they like you know when they
high-res like [ __ ] super mario 64 and
like unreal engine 4 you're like
this is disgusting put it back to the
the bits i i like i can't even play
[ __ ] mario games what are you all
about
when you see clips of like [ __ ] zelda
ocarina of time in like 144 hertz 10k
i'm like yeah no i look at that sound
like hell yeah i'm like put that [ __ ]
[ __ ] awesome no dude i don't want my
pawn like that i want my pawn always a
generation or two behind my anime okay
what the [ __ ] was that analogy i'm sorry
how did how did you how did you actually
compare
low quality porn to making [ __ ] super
mario
at hd equality yeah what was that
because right you know sometimes the
animation's jank and i like that
because it's like thank you for
reminding me where the [ __ ] i am you
know
what are you all about because sometimes
what i'm talking about
i don't want my my hentai to look
exactly and feel exactly the same as
anime
are you like lucid dreaming while you're
watching inside like what like
are you like are you awake when you're
watching yes
well then what are you talking about i
don't understand what i'm saying i watch
hentai to keep myself grounded no no no
no
no you want you want a differentiation
between hentai and anime yeah
but i'd fall for like i don't understand
why
you don't want high quality hentai yeah
that's that's all i want i just want
high quality hentai i look at i look at
something that's like okay if there's
like a break this happens all the time
with hentai there's like a brand new one
that comes out right like fresh off
whatever [ __ ] site you're on
and you look at the [ __ ] poster and
i'm like this looks like it was made in
1982. yeah yeah and yet you look at it
it's like animated in 2020. i'm like
what who who who i feel like when i said
i wanted to bring back the 80s anime
aesthetic i didn't mean it like this
yeah i really feel like it's the inverse
it's always like god tier
cover art for the new ones and you click
on it it's [ __ ] queen bee yeah